if you're wanting to stand out and it
feels like there's too much competition
another level
would be this YouTube channel is for
beginners we had Alex hermosi speak at
our event and we had Layla hermosi on
the podcast a while back now Layla
hermosi she really operates as like a
operator of acquisition.com and she has
expressed that like her passion is
Advanced business operations one of the
cool things about her Channel that I
love is it's like really not for
everybody The Experience level that she
is helping with is maybe intermediate to
even Advanced compared to 99 of the
information that's on YouTube I would
also argue that while I do believe her
channel will grow large it probably
won't grow as large as beginner advice
or people that just want to start that
self-awareness is a superpower